[Music]
what do these animals have in common
more than you might think along with
over 5,000 other species they're mammals
or members of class Mammalia all mammals
are vertebrates meaning they have
backbones but mammals are distinguished
from other vertebrates by a number of
shared features that includes warm blood
body hair or fur the ability to breathe
using lungs and nourishing their young
with milk but despite these similarities
these creatures also have many
biological differences and one of the
most remarkable is how they give birth
let's start with the most familiar
placental mammals this group includes
humans cats dogs giraffes and even the
blue whale the biggest animal on earth
its placenta a solid disk of blood rich
tissue attaches to the wall of the
uterus to support the developing embryo
the placenta is what keeps the calf
alive during pregnancy directly
connected to the mother's blood supply
it funnels nutrients and oxygen straight
into the calf's body via the umbilical
cord and also exports its waste
placental mammals can spend far longer
inside the womb than other mammals baby
blue whales for instance spend almost a
full year inside their mother the
placenta keeps the calf alive right up
until its birth when the umbilical cord
breaks and the newborns own respiratory
circulatory and waste disposal systems
take over measuring about 23 feet a
newborn calf is already able to swim
it'll spend the next six months drinking
225 liters of its mother's thick fatty
milk per day meanwhile in Australia you
can find a second type of mammal
marsupials
marsupial babies are so tiny and
delicate when they're born that they
must continue developing in the mother's
pouch take the cool one of the world's
smallest marsupials which weighs only 18
milligrams at birth the equivalent of
about 30 sugar grains the kangaroo
another marsupial gives birth to a
single jellybean sized baby at a time
the baby crawls down the middle of the
mothers three vaginas then must climb up
to the pouch where she spends the next 6
to 11 months suckling even after the
baby kangaroo leaves this warm Haven
she'll return to suckle milk sometimes
she's just one of three babies her
mother is caring for a female kangaroo
can often simultaneously support one
inside her uterus and another in her
pouch in unfavorable conditions female
kangaroos can pause their pregnancies
when that happens she's able to produce
two different kinds of milk one for her
newborn and one for her older Joey the
word Mammalia means of the breast which
is a bit of a misnomer because while
kangaroos do produce milk from nipples
in their pouches they don't actually
have breasts nor do monotremes the third
and arguably strangest example of
mammalian birth there were once hundreds
of monitoring species but there are only
five left four species of echidnas and
the duck-billed platypus
the name monotreme means one hole
referring to the single orifice they use
for reproduction excretion and
egg-laying like birds reptiles fish
dinosaurs and others these species lay
eggs instead of giving birth to live
young their eggs are soft shelled and
when their babies hatch they suckle milk
from pores on their mother's body until
they're large enough to feed themselves
despite laying eggs and other
adaptations that we associate more with
non mammals like the duckbill platypuses
webbed feet bill and the venomous spur
males have on their feet they are in
fact mammals that's because they share
the defining characteristics of Mammalia
and are evolutionarily linked to the
rest of the class whether placental
marsupial or monotreme each of these
creatures and its unique birthing
methods however bizarre have succeeded
for many millennia in bringing new life
and diversity into the mammal kingdom
you
[Music]